on va perdre le rappeur une interview
prise de tête
on bouge pas bien or justement à
continuer à se prendre la tête là
imaginez vous faites un enfant une fille
mais vous en fait à une autre fille
est-ce que vous demandé d'avorter
ça dépend si j'ai dit si j'ai 18 ans et
que j'ai pas de thunes pour le faire
vivre et que je sais que j'ai des
problèmes de ravine j'ai pas de pas de
boulot pas 24 50 ans était milliardaire
à leur tour est le fondeur d'or du gard
d'accouchement ce qu'on tombe jardin ou
votre mère est atteint d'une maladie
incurable et vous demandent l'euthanasie
oui non je suis moi je pourrais pas le
faire parce que c'est ma mère mais je
comprendrais qu'elles veulent
si elle souffre trop qu'elle veut
arrêter ça nous laisserait les toubibs
le faire si elles demandent si elle me
regarde et me dit oh il faut trouver une
solution mais je vais pas l'arrêt à la
gare d affaires se regarder à ce frère
quoi moi je n'ai toujours pas merci la
boîte aujourd'hui je voyais avec les
pièces d'un à bouffer toujours le
sourire si la voie dans un lit d'hôpital
et qu'elle demande un truc je pense que
ça peut être entre guillemets humain de
craquer je pense quand même parce que
s'ils pas laisser souffrir sa mère c'est
quand même un type type a violé et tué
trois gamines de 11 ans peine de mort
pas peine de mort c'est difficile c'est
un peu comme ont pris la peine de mort
mais quand si ces méga mensah se couche
pour elle c'est tout ça ouais donc ouais
non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai si si si
c'est un enfant et que tu vois quelqu'un
kabyle est un enfant qui est tout petit
dans la fonction tu peux aller faire des
choses de fou vous avez des amis
homosexuels c'est un jeu de l'esprit qui
est en ville âmes qui envisage qui
envisagent d'adopter un enfant
vouloir conseillé de le faire vous leur
dites que c'est pas bien alors dit que
c'est pas bien
vous croyez en dieu vous je crois en
dieu
si vous tuez différentes façons de prix
ouais si vous deviez choisir une
religion vous choisiriez laquelle
peut-être la religion musulmane parce
que quand le plus avec
avec quand tu roules tout simplement
content représente jésus blond aux yeux
bleus
ouais je suis noir plutôt l'islam mais
plutôt l'histoire